and i know a lot of you people listen to
podcasts and [__] you know i was on
joe's podcast one day and we're talking
about and we're talking about pills you
know they're talking about pills and the
effects of pills
and i get all excited you know my pills
i never did pills i wasn't really a big
pill guy but i was like 16.
i had a couple quaaludes some of those
cosby pills right
and i used to get [__] up i love those
things you could eat that was a lemon
or aurora 714 and when you wanted to do
it you referred them as a 714 express
we're going on the express
tonight [__] yeah you'll be all [__]
up and [__] tremendous
you drink a little pupa vodka you ever
drink poop vodka with some gatorade and
then [__]
you talk to people their eyebrows go on
fire and [__]
it's like eight dollars for a keg of
pupa vodka and [__]
so one night i went up to the pool hall
to get a [__] quaalude and i saw my
friend lucy up there
and she was banging i go loose and we
grew up together we had like swamp spit
in the eighth grade lucy looked good
and i knew her for a long time i'm like
oh my god that's who's [__] i'm gonna
eat
god just put her in my [__] bath i'm
gonna eat her [__] that's the one i
wanna eat
and we always had like a kind of a crush
on each other she wasn't dating nobody i
wasn't dating nobody
so i told the story about one night i
got you you put 50
away and you forget where it is and you
get pissed off and after like a month
you look at a shoe and you go oh [__]
and you find it how excited do you get
like oh [__]
we were talking about pills and awesome
it came to me that oh
[__] one night i ate a quaalude and i
broke into lucy's house and ate her
[__] and left right
and as i was saying the story i felt
terrible right i'm like i can't believe
i'm [__] saying this
but it was already out already right so
i'm like oh [__]
so i get in the car i call my friend and
jersey let me get lucy's number i call
her
i we haven't spoken in 20 years since
everybody go loosely i told this story
about breaking into your house
and eat your [__] and she's like i
forgot all about it
i'm like well anyway listen i said this
to her she goes don't say it again what
did you say it on it well podcast she
goes don't say it again i got kids and a
husband
i'll never say it again too late
somebody animated and put it on youtube
so they kept it up there
so now i'm getting like little twits
from people in facebook joey how could
you break into somebody's house and eat
that [__] and leave
it's not right we used to like you and
like i said i'm a catholic i'm not a bad
person i felt guilty you know i felt
guilty
i mean i believe in karma i don't want
somebody breaking into my house eating
my wife and my daughter
and [__] leaving you know what i'm
saying and carmel comes with a weird
[__] receipt they always leave a
receipt comment so i got a little weird
about it
but then i started thinking i'm like
what the [__] is wrong with people in
society today like a one like there was
a couple guys and a couple women
and a couple of women like oh my god if
you ever busted into my house i dial the
police i'm thinking to myself you know
what
with all the match.coms and the
christian mingles and all this [__]
somebody breaks into your house eats
your [__]
little leaves
i know some of you women like joey what
the [__] are you saying again
somebody breaks into your house
eat your [__] and leaves
and granted i didn't eat her [__] good
it was my first [__] i didn't even
touch it i had my hands
i didn't even lick the [__] i looked
like the thigh the belly button
up here i would hell i just must have
pre-came and ran out of there
and i never said none again until that
day i remember i'm like oh [__] i broke
into a house made a [__]
what really shocked me was people's
behavior towards me i thought oh my god
i can't believe it
and i started thinking about i mean what
the [__] so even if a cop comes and says
what happened some chubby guy broke into
my house
ate my [__] and left
did he tie you up no did he shoot the
dog no
did he rob you no so wait a second
he just came in here ate your [__]
and left yes
no harm no foul i mean what the [__]
that's a party where i come from on the
west side
and some women i get it i get it i know
you're very sensitive i love you i know
what you're saying
but i mean you think guys act like this
you think half these [__] hey listen
these guys love you women
they love you they took you out tonight
you're dating you're married we love you
i love my [__] wife
with everything i go i don't want to
cheat on my nothing i would never want
to cheat on my wife it's bad karma
but but
and this is a big [__] butt so hear
me out okay
hear me out before you judge me i'm not
a bad guy hear me out all of you are
going to go home tonight maybe you got
to do an activity tomorrow you're tired
the kids whatever the [__] grandpa
my father whatever the [__] you want to
go home tonight you go home you mix it
up a little bit maybe you don't mix it
up
sometimes i don't want to go to bed you
ever have that on friday nights you know
what i've been going my wife wants to go
to bed early
let me just scroll and see what time you
ever just scroll and see what's coming
on in 15 minutes or there's nothing
coming on [__] i'll go to bed
and you pray this song i'm saying you're
like oh [__]
purple rain's coming off
oh [__] yeah and you get up and put your
boxer shorts on
right you get your flip-flops you get
your little t-shirt with the hole in it
you put your [__] robe on you go out
to the garage you hit like 10 [__]
bong hits
you come in you make a peanut butter and
jelly sandwich right
you grab the cat you get the remote
control
you get a yoo-hoo
and you sit there and you're watching
[__] whatever jungle love
and all of a sudden you hear your window
open up
and you see a beautiful woman's thigh
come through the glass i mean a
beautiful thigh the foot's got cream on
it
the toes are red she got heels on with
an ankle strap
she's [__] throwing heat the [__] the
thigh is sunburned she's [__] banging
also she climbs through the window and
she's a chubby girl with a red mohawk
and a bikini top on with a cute little
figure and she looks you straight in the
[__] eye and goes
i don't care how much you love jesus or
your wife
not one guy in he's gonna go
there's a chubby woman in my living room
with bad intentions [__] no
you look at how you make eye contact
right back
and you play that [__] hand out
if things go sour [__] it i'll hit her
in the head with the you who bottle
and i'll dial 9-1-1 i don't know what
happened officer
but if not she comes to the window
she stays eye contact with you and she
walks to you like a panther
she gets right up next to you she drops
she takes your [__] yoke out
she knows there's people in the house
she sucks it like a savage
but very quietly like an american sniper
like
nobody can hear a suck in your dick it's
like a dog whistle
and when she finishes she puts your dick
back in your shorts she taps it twice
for good luck
she walks backwards
she opens the window and she jumps out
of the window
takes the garbage can on the way down
the whole thing
not one man in here not one he is he's
gonna go help
hurry up dial 9-1-1 some woman just suck
my dick
call the priest call the therapist [__]
no
[__] no not one man in here is gonna
yell
you're gonna look at that [__] window
and this is where it gets funny this is
where it gets the weirdest ever
because it doesn't matter what you are
white black
latino irish a jew
german isis an arab
it don't matter what [__] man you are
at that point in time you know look at
that window for about eight minutes
with a hope with a look of hope
and sadness
and after about eight minutes you're
gonna look up you're gonna do the sign
of the cross
and you're gonna say thank you god for
finally [__] coming through
because that's all a man wants somebody
to come in
suck that dick i'll leave
i love you guys thank you very much
[Applause]
joey coco diaz everybody keep it going